so how is hypertension treated
the first line of defense is lifestyle
changes which is what we mentioned in it
as far as prevention in the previous
video eating healthy foods lowering salt
intake and all these different things
we want to make sure that we live a
healthy life so that we don't have to
necessarily deal with hypertension and
if we do
have to deal with hypertension these
lifestyle changes can still be a form of
treatment
and they can help to reduce um issues
with hypertension they can actually
lower the hypertension
now why why is it we want
lifestyle changes before we think about
medications why is lifestyle changes or
why are they the
first line of defense the reason why is
because drugs have these things called
side effects
and they can be bad and harmful for
patients
so the best thing to do is make sure
that we don't have to take drugs don't
have to take medications
that's the ideal
but if there are medications are the
sort of the second line of defense
so the kind of drugs that are used to
treat hypertension are
anti-hypertensive drugs
so these are these drugs are not for
people
with pre-hypertension they are only for
patients who do indeed have hypertension
and
it is not controlled just by lifestyle
changes
the prescription uh drugs that are that
are
given to a patient what is prescribed is
based on a variety of things and it can
include
age or even existing medical conditions
that they already have
and what's best for them as far as
combinations of drugs combinations of
different
antihypertensive drugs are possible
and actually common for many patients
i do want to you to recall that this
idea of
blood pressure equaling the stroke
volume times the heart rate times the
resistance not equally necessarily but
being related to those values so if we
can reduce
reduce any of these values
to lower blood pressure
that's what these drugs are going to
want to do
so when it comes to the classifying the
drugs that treat hypertension you should
think about the abcds of hypertension
drug classes
a 10 stands for ace inhibitors
and ace inhibitors are of course
angiotensin convertase
or converting enzyme inhibitors and
oftentimes
these drugs their names will end in
prill
so if you see a drug name that ends in
prill it's probably an ace inhibitor not
necessarily but it's probably
so what exactly is the function of these
drugs what's the function of the ace
inhibitor
the function is to block
angiotensin converting enzyme activity
so basically
what that what that does is angiotensin
converting enzyme what that does is that
turns angiotensin 1 into angiotensin ii
so that would happen
that wouldn't happen or if it did happen
it would happen much less often so we'd
have
no angiotensin ii created from
angiotensin 1 or at least we would have
less angiotensin 2 created from
angiotensin 1.
so what are the effects of of blocking
that angiotensin converted
converting enzyme activity well we
either have no
sympathetic activation or we'd have less
of it so
we'd have no increase let me put this in
red here actually let's do blue
we would have no increase in sympathetic
activity
so if there's no increase in sympathetic
activity that means we'd have
a lower stroke volume and a lower heart
rate and thus
a lower blood pressure another thing
we'd have no or less of is we'd have no
vasoconstriction or less
vasoconstriction
which would mean that we'd have less
resistance again
lower blood pressure if we have no
sodium or water retention then we would
have
a lower blood volume and a lower blood
volume means a lower stroke volume
if we have no anti-diuretic hormone or
or less anti-diarrhea hormone or no
water retention or less water retention
again that would decrease the stroke
volume no aldosterone secretion
again decreases stroke volume all of
these
effects decrease the blood pressure
another thing that classified under a is
angiotensin ii receptor blockers
which are already as arb so sometimes
they're called arbs
these are often end in a sartan so if
you see a drug name that ends in sartan
it's probably an angiotensin ii receptor
blocker and what these things do
is they block the effects of angiotensin
ii
by blocking the binding
they block the binding
of angiotensin ii on cell receptors so
what are the effects here well they're
basically the same as the above right
they're going to stop the effects of
angiotensin ii which are all these
effects here
so but why would angiotensins 2 receptor
blockers
be prescribed over angiotensin
converting enzyme inhibitors
well the simple sort of reply is that
but there are
perhaps adverse side effects
from ace inhibitors so if a patient is
prescribed ace inhibitors they happen to
have
negative side effects and angiotensin ii
receptor blocker
might be considered next up
is b c and d so b
stands for beta blockers and these beta
blockers they block
the binding of epinephrine and
norepinephrine at
beta adrenergic receptors so basically
what that does is that
reduces sympathetic activity
so if there's if epinephrine and
norepinephrine which are part of the
sympathetic nervous system if they're
not active they're not being able to
exert their effects we're going to have
less sympathetic activity
beta blockers often end in olal
olol so if you see a name that ends in
olol
might be a beta blocker so if we have
no or less sympathetic activity then
what we have is we have
um no increased contractility of the
heart
and thus we have a lower stroke volume
lower stroke volume lower blood pressure
we also would have no
no increase in heart rate so we'd have a
lower heart rate which again would give
us a
lower blood pressure so that's how beta
blockers work
what about c calcium channel blockers
or ccbs so calcium channel blockers
often end in peen or pine i'm not
exactly sure how that would be
pronounced but
what these do is they block the flow
of calcium through calcium ion channels
and what that does
is that stops um
that basically makes it so that we have
no muscle contractions
so calcium ions are required to
to flow into a cell to cause muscle cell
contractions
so if we have smooth muscle in the blood
or cardiac muscle in the heart
those things cannot contract so we have
is we have
less vasoconstriction
which means that the the vessels
themselves could stay dilated
that would be less resistance and a
lower blood pressure
in the heart we would have a lower
contractile force
and lower electrical activity just in
general
and those would both lead to a lower
stroke volume
and a lower heart rate which of course
all these go again
to decrease blood pressure
d or diet for diuretics these things
often end in zide
or at least i'd just go with i'd what
these things do
what diuretics do is they increase the
production and excretion
of urine so basically
what they do is they eliminate water
and salt or sodium so if we lose water
we have less water we have a smaller
blood volume
smaller blood volume lower stroke volume
lower blood pressure
so all these things have different ways
of lowering blood pressure but it always
comes back down to
decreasing either the stroke volume
heart rate or resistance
there are some other um drugs
including alpha blockers renin
inhibitors aldosterone receptor
antagonists vasodilators
alpha 2 agonists and endothelial
receptor blockers they are also used
to treat hypertension but they're not as
common as the ones mentioned above
hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching